so we left off in part one getting
pretty close to finding our n of T that
satisfies the logistic differential
equation where its initial condition is
between zero and K and now we just have
to really just do some algebra to finish
things up so we left with this that for
our n of T this must be true
now we could use a little bit of
logarithm properties to rewrite this
left-hand side as the logarithm of have
the logarithm of something minus
logarithm of something else that's going
to be the first something the logarithm
of the first something divided by the
second something one minus n over K and
this is of course going to be equal to
all this business that we have it's
going to be equal to actually let me
just write it it's going to be equal to
equal to R times T plus C plus C and now
what we could do this is the same thing
as saying that that e to the RT plus C
is going to be equal to this thing right
over here this this the natural log of
this is equal to the exponent that I
have to raise e to to get to this right
over here so I can just write that we
could just write or another way of
thinking about as we're taking we could
take e to if this is equal to that we
could take e to this power on the left
hand side and e to this power on this
right hand side and they should be equal
so e to this power is just going to be
what's inside the parenthesis it's just
going to be n it's just going to be n
over 1 minus 1 minus n over K I'll do
that in green color so you can just keep
track of where things came from is equal
to e to this business is equal to e to
the R T are out of the T and white are T
plus C plus C now this I could rewrite
if I want if I want to if I have e to
something plus something else I could
rewrite this as to the RT times
e times e to the C and just to simplify
things this is just going to be another
constant here and I could you know if
this is C I could call it C 1 but I'm
just going to call that a constant so I
could just say that that's going to be
equal to some constant times e to the RT
and now we just need to solve for n and
once again if at any point where while
we're working on this you get inspired
feel free to solve for n so let's see
one way to solve for n let's see we
could take the reciprocal of both sides
of this we're going to get 1 let me draw
a line here just so you know that we're
so let me draw a line so if we take the
reciprocal of both sides of this we're
going to get 1 over N 1 minus n over K
over light-green n is equal to is equal
to and so let's you know we could say
it's equal to it's equal to 1 over C
times e to the negative RT but 1 over C
that's just going to be another constant
so I could write 1 over C here when I
take the reciprocal but once again this
is going to be another constant so I'm
going to be a little bit of hint a
little bit hand wavy says well ok we're
going to get another constant here I
could have called you know this C 1 this
C 2 I could call this C 3 if I want to
make it clear that these are not going
to be the same number this is e to this
power this is the reciprocal of that
actually maybe I'll do that just to make
it a little bit a little bit clearer
that would have been C 1 right over
there and so this is going to be sorry
the reciprocal of this is C 3 and e to
the negative the reciprocal of U to the
Archies e to the negative RT e to the
negative e to the negative R e to the
negative RT and let's see if we divide
the numerator and the denominator by n
or if we divide i wondering when we
divide this term by n we're going to get
so this term by n is going to be 1 over
n and then this term by n is just going
to be minus 1 over K so this is just
going to be minus 1 over K is equal to
this is equal to this business
so copy and paste it's going to be equal
to that this is good algebra practice
here now let's see we could take this
one over K add it to both sides so let's
do that so let me just cut so let me cut
and paste it I'm going to add it to both
sides so that should be a plus 1 over K
so plus 1 over K and now to solve for n
I just take the reciprocal of both sides
so I'm going to get I'm going to get N
and I'll write it in kind of the
function notation and of T make sure we
make make my tea in white since I've
been taking the trouble all this time of
rewriting this in white is equal to 1
over is going to be equal to 1 over all
of this business is going to be equal to
1 over all of this business so copy and
paste is going to be equal to that and
that by itself that's by itself is
already interesting that by itself is
already interesting so I could write it
like this and if I want if I don't like
let's see well yeah I could just if I
don't like having this K you know kind
of a fraction in a fraction I could
rewrite it as actually maybe I'll do it
over here and of n of T is equal to I'll
just multiply the numerator and the
denominator by I'll just multiply it
actually let me just let me just leave
it like that for now and what I'm going
to do what I'm not what I'm now going to
do is I'm going to say well look you
know we're assuming that n of 0 is n
sub-nought so we're assuming that n of 0
and of 0 is equal to n sub-nought so
let's write this thing let's solve for
the constant let's figure out what what
this could be if we know what our
initial condition is so n of 0 n of 0 is
going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to 1 1 over when
T is 0 this is just going to be equal
one so it's going to be our constant C
three plus one over k plus one over the
maximum population that our population
that our environment can handle and
that's going to be equal to and not and
now we can solve for our constant so we
get yeah I'm probably gonna need a lot
of real estate for this I can take the
reciprocal of both sides again so this
is something that we're doing a lot of C
3 plus 1 over K is equal to 1 over N
naught this is equal to 1 over n not
just took the reciprocal of both sides
and so we get our constant C 3 is equal
to 1 over N naught minus 1 over K minus
1 over K and so we can rewrite our
solution which we'll call the logistic
function we get we get this is fun now n
of T n of T is equal to 1 over our
constant is this so it's going to be let
me copy and paste this so copy and paste
it's going to be that that's our
constant so it's going to be that times
e to the negative RT to the negative R
times T plus 1 over K plus 1 over K and
if we don't like having all of these
denominators in the done all of these
fractions in the denominator
why don't we multiply everything times
the numerator and the denominator by n
naught K so I'm going to multiply the
numerator times n not K and I'm going to
multiply the denominator by n naught K
and not K and so what do we get this is
all going to be equal to in the
numerator I have n naught times K and
naught times K and in the denominator
I'm going to have let's see if I
multiply this term right over here times
n
kay I'm going to have K if I multiply
this term times n not K I'm going to
have and not so it's going to be minus
an naught minus n naught times e to the
negative RT times e to the negative RT
negative RT and then if I multiply this
times and not K I'm going to get n
naught so plus and not and there you
have it we have found a solution for the
logistic differential equation we will
call this logistic function and in
future videos we will explore it more
and we will see that it actually does if
you were to plot this I encourage you to
do so either on the internet you could
try Wolfram Alpha if you're on your
graphing calculator you will see that it
has the exact properties that we want it
to have it starts at n naught it starts
to increase at increasing rates but then
it starts to slow down as we reach our
maximum population and so that is
actually a very neat function you know
if you model a population with this you
can kind of start to make predictions
about what might the population be a
time you know whatever and so hopefully
you found that satisfying